welcome back to CBS mornings it's been
nearly two months since a massive train
derailment spread dangerous chemicals in
East Palestine Ohio raising urgent
questions for the company at the center
of This Disaster well yesterday the
Norfolk Southern CEO his name is Alan
Shaw returned to Capitol Hill he told
Senators that his company is very
committed to better safety standards but
he stopped short of endorsing
legislation to do that Roxanna siberi
has been speaking with residents of East
Palestine and she joins us with that
part of the story Roxanna good morning
to you
good morning Gail many residents in this
area continue to voice skepticism toward
Norfolk Southern despite the company's
repeated pledges to clean up East
Palestine at yesterday's Senate hearing
lawmakers pressed CEO Alan Shaw on what
his company is doing to make sure a
disaster like this never happens again
they compromise safety cut costs to
boost profits the communities along
their route be damned facing accusations
that Norfolk Southern prioritizes
profits over safety whose responsibility
was it to prevent this preventable
accident Senator we are responsible for
safety on our Network CEO Alan Shaw told
Senators he supports some aspects of a
bipartisan Bill aimed at preventing
another toxic train derailment like the
one in East Palestine Ohio many
components of the Vance Brown build that
we fully support like implementing newer
more secure tanker cars which some
experts say might have mitigated the
disaster
but he resisted requiring trains to have
at minimum two-person Cruise not aware
of any data that
links crew size was safety they should
really be listening to the residents we
spoke with resident Misty Allison on
Tuesday before she flew to Washington DC
to testify before the committee this
preventable accident has put a Scarlet
Letter on our town businesses are
struggling our home values are
plummeting we're in the planning stages
of developing a long-term medical
compensation fund a property value
Assurance program
and a longer term water testing program
back in East Palestine cleanup continues
the EPA says more than seven and a half
million gallons of Wastewater have been
shipped out for treatment and more than
8 000 tons of contaminated soil but so
far the agency has said the air and
Municipal Water are safe I feel safe
being here and here we are stuck we
watched Shaw's testimony with East
Palestine small business owner Joe
Samick
sounds like a broken record he
took disaster his repair shop has mostly
sat idle and one of his two daughters
broke out in rashes
the father my goal is to keep them safe
and right now I feel like I'm doing the
opposite of that he and his neighbors
live less than a mile from the
derailment site but technically they're
outside city limits
they don't qualify for Norfolk Southern
support to relocate temporarily
you want to leave East Palestine
absolutely
I fear that this is going to be
something that
terrorizes this town for
quite a few years if not forever
to find a solution but he and several
other residents tell us the company
needs to do more faster meanwhile for
those who do live within the city limits
the railroad operator says it's
providing families with funds to
relocate for now Vlad
Roxanna thank you very much